here we go all right welcome to
simulation I'm Alan Sakia and today we
have the pleasure sitting down with Paul
Penn Garrow hello hey I don't know thank
you so much for coming onto the show
well it's pleasure I love coming to San
Francisco and this is an extra treat yes
and I will definitely have to stop by in
Detroit yeah yes I love your work that's
amazing
bringing some really important
conversations to our world Paul has an
awesome background in cybernetics as
president of general cybernetics and go
for seven years and then now he is the
associate professor and chair at the
master Fine Arts program of interaction
design at the College of Creative
Studies in Detroit and so that's also
very cool school interesting school been
around 100 years 100 year olds started
in arts and crafts yep and in that
tradition but the master's program is
relatively new my program is only about
three years old yes yes and this is a
very important conversation because of
systems thinking I think is a really
important way to see the world to lens
with which to see the world
we just had rease-jones on yesterday and
we were talking in great depth I
actually messaged him last night
wondering if the way that we were
talking about biological systems and the
way we were talking about mechanical
systems and sociological systems if we
could use cybernetics to describe that
and he said yeah totally yeah totally in
fact cybernetics began as an interest in
a wide range of disciplines to think
about systems no matter what they're
made out of but as having a purpose yes
it was a discipline that says don't care
if it's a cell or a body or a thermostat
or anything can we look at the world as
a system as systems that have a goal and
if they have a goal how do they achieve
that goal so that started in the 30s and
mostly in the 40s and it's incredibly
influential still although usually not
by its name because it's been
misinterpreted as we talked about a
little bit but feedback we have the word
feedback in the
yeah zeitgeist now because of because of
cybernetics if you go to the Google
Ngram you know the thing that plots how
many words have been used in the books
that it happens to have but probably
pretty representative feedback kind of
goes along like this and then all of a
sudden in the 42 goes of food and it's
still going up so feedback as a concept
really started there and it was
formalized in a wide range of
disciplines yes and I find it incredibly
powerful in a wide range of areas
especially in interaction design yeah
and maybe you go ahead and tie in let's
get some relatable examples first of
them just tie into sure you know
actually design so there's some really
really simple examples would be like you
said the purpose of a cell or the
purpose of a body or the purpose of a
mechanical system like you set a
thermostat yeah yeah go walk us down
so the thermostats a great example
because we have it every day but the
prior example also helps explain what
the word means so people think of cyber
this and cyber that because it's been
used widely William Gibson coin
cyberspace in one of his novels and that
began this trend to have it mean a bunch
of other things but you heard it here
cybernetics comes from a Greek word
meaning to steer or to pilot as in
piloting a ship so what's that mean that
means I'm trying to go over there and I
start out and I'm doing fine and then I
get blown off by wind and tide and then
I'm thinking wait a minute that's my
actual goal my desired goal this is my
current goal my current state so my
goals are off so what I have to do is I
have to use this feedback of this
difference we call it error but we mean
that in a good sense error that tells
you what's wrong not hey you made a
mistake not that but an error and you
compensate for that error by turning
this way and then maybe you get blown
this way by wind and tide and you go too
far and so you have to compensate so
this act of steering of acting sensing
comparing to what you want
acting sensing comparing to what you
want and then correcting yeah that's a
simple feedback loop and that's the
meaning of cybernetics to pilot or to
steal in fact I'm told
in Greek it means the art of steering
yeah
not just the steering so that's the
basic example thermostats work the same
way right you've got the temperature in
a room and the sensor says well it's a
little bit cool in here so I need to
turn up the heat so the air gets warm
from the heater the hot air enters the
room and changes the sensor the sensor
sends its signal to this comparator and
says well am i on course or off course
do I have the right temperature or not
and it gives the heater the proper
instruction whether to stay on or to go
off and simple feedback is that yes and
it's so important it's hard really to
emphasize every intelligent system has
intelligence because it has this
feedback relationship with a given
environment I don't want to jump ahead
but there's a thing in AI that says
that's an intelligent machine
well well wait a minute in what context
is it intelligent in some context a
thermostat is really smart mm-hmm but
all of a sudden when it's 20 degrees
below zero and it's never that way it's
not very smart because it can't manage
that situation so it's designed for a
certain range of capabilities yeah
anyway so that's the core cybernetics
the other thing to think about is that
it's a circular thing yeah and and not
just going in circles as in ending up in
the same place but it's a spiral you
advance you go for that it's perfect the
Greek word to steer the art of steering
yeah it really explains it well and also
the circular system so it's it's you you
do something and then you analyze what
you did and then you steer yourself yeah
again to the next and then you do Anna
last year you're you're constantly
comparing to what you want what you have
now that's first-order feedback what
might happen though is along the way you
say well is this the thing I really want
is there something else I could want and
then you can change your goal but wait a
minute
this first order loop is just worried
about the goal that you've set if
something else changes your goal
that's an outer loop so now you have a
second order of feedback the outer loop
changes the goal of the inner loop it's
like we say hey let's let's go to dinner
and then we work on it for a while and
we decide no there's no good time we
don't have food tastes in common and so
on but then we said wait a minute why
were we going to dinner well cuz you
just wanted to talk well let's talk over
tea exactly exactly
so this consciousness of setting goals
and questioning those goals is something
that cybernetics lets you do consciously
and explicitly and before that there was
no science for that so what did you mean
in your video when you said that science
mostly takes a linear approach versus
cybernetics takes a circular approach
yeah give us an example then of the
scientific linear one - force there was
this extraordinary Feeny's character who
wrote very very eloquently on a lot of
these topics and I recommend reading him
Vaughn Forster he's worth a really
tremendous influence on the on the first
generation of cyber nutrition's which by
the way included Margaret Mead and
Gregory Bateson and John von Neumann and
Norbert Wiener and many of you may know
but Heights used to say remember that
science comes from the same word root
word as schism which means to cut and he
would then explain that science works
because it tries to explain something
this big and it says well no that's too
complicated I can't do that so let me
just look at this narrow thing no anyway
that's kind of hard so let's narrow it
down to this little tiny piece of piece
of the world right we're gonna look at
some photons now we're gonna look at
some you know thermo electric effect
over here and it's cutting and cutting
and cutting until it's so small that you
can say something about it now what you
can say a scientific law is profound
it's like wow that's really powerful you
equals mc-squared oh my god but the
problem is that you've cut the world
into tiny pieces and you've said eh
causes be and you've said something
profound about that but you haven't
allowed you disallow in science a causes
B causes C causes a so basic science is
all about splitting the world into
smaller and smaller pieces whereas now
we have system science and that is
interested in these circular causal
things that yeah and all of that but
cybernetics has as its as at its core
this idea of circularity yeah and that's
what pints first said good that was a
good explanation
we typically host very very smart
scientists that I went super far in
depth in their field you know and a lot
of time they will have cut cut cut cut
cut down down down and it's really
profound the realization that they get
at this very very small yeah yet level
and then that can typically help with
something like disease or can help with
something like an advancement in
technology which is great and then
furthermore to take that discovery and
to try and figure out how it plays a
part in the system that is the next kind
of step in the direction of maybe
science relating to the direct linear
but then also how it relates that well
why do we need the phrase systems
science that says that science is not of
itself systemic in this way that we want
as science used to say science can say
more and more about less and less
because it's cutting things down in this
way he also used to claim the science
comes from the same word as [ __ ]
but I'm not sure that's true he said
that but I can verify that so ok so the
so the example we have a thermostat that
we have both we have here even the human
body has so many weight I mean you
you're you're hungry well what's your
what's your action eat a banana yeah and
once you eat the banana
what do you realize oh you're not hungry
anymore ok back to back to work so
there's there's many different ways to
so I guess
let's ask about how this applies to
interaction design I think that's gonna
be really interesting and then I think
we have a couple other really good
avenues to walk down as well so yeah I'm
sure you do yeah that's great well in
this program that I chair in Detroit at
the College for Creative Studies in
interaction design the invitation to
take the job was to design the
curriculum and for some years I've
taught with a close colleague Hugh Debra
Lee a course when I was in the Bay Area
at Stanford for Terry Winograd of course
essentially in cybernetics and design
and the idea was that if you learned how
simple feedback loops work and then how
nested feedbacks loop feedback loops
work then you can imagine designing for
this thing because if I do something it
tells me it heard me or it vibrates or
it blinks or it disappears when I touch
it so simple feedback like that is a bit
like when I when I come to this mm-hmm
I get to it and that gives me feedback
so simple feedback but more so and much
more subtle is what are the
possibilities I have here how can it
express to me if it thinks I'm trying to
do something make a reservation how does
it expose to me the options related to
that reservation and that's a that's the
idea that I can change my mind and I can
change my goal and so on and so forth so
interaction design begins with feedback
another aspect that's a little deeper is
how powerful is the thing that I'm being
given for example thermostat in this
room can heat the room when it's 30
degrees Fahrenheit 20 degrees Fahrenheit
but it doesn't do so well when it's
minus 20 degrees Fahrenheit
because it's been designed to work
within a range and there's a very
important idea in cybernetics called
variety which is the capacity of a
system to respond to the disturbances
it's like in some boats if I'm piloting
a ship back to the example some storms I
can go through in some storms I can
because that's a fundamental limitation
of the design of the thing
so it makes students aware of
limitations of their designing and
forces us all to be conscious of those
limitations but where it gets really
interesting
and this was a revelation to me when I
first came across it was in order to
understand things and to go through
pre-existing patterns but also to
imagine new patterns to examine what I
know and to learn what I don't know
requires a conversation yes and even in
my own head when I'm saying should I do
this or this that's a conversation
mm-hmm so this is a conversation you
open with it right how is it
conversation well as a consequence we
know different things after than before
so I've learned some things about you
hopefully vice versa
but more importantly we learn what's
possible through conversation mhm and if
you learn what's possible then you have
more choices and if you have more
choices than the world is a better place
and so again back to Hines he had
something that he called the ethical
imperative which is I shall act always
so as to increase the number of choices
yes yes I shall act always to increase
the number of choices and as a designer
that's the most ethical thing so I'm an
interaction designer and I'm
constraining people but what I what I do
and don't put on this screen but if I
constrain their choices too much that's
a little bit of a wiggle word how do I
get around this problem of overly
constraining people it's a serious issue
so on Amazon I've got a lot of choices
and a lot of it's not good for me and so
students say well you don't show the
people the bad choices for you who says
they're bad choices the designer the
person etc so it's a very very
complicated thing I've gone deep in
there all of a sudden it's a very
complex thing to imagine how you can
help people understand their choices and
design an environment in which they can
increase the number of choices but
unique conversation to do that
and so studying conversation as a system
that has an evolution that gets
somewhere that sets goals changes goals
proposes and removes and elaborates
goals is critical to interaction zone so
there are series of models which you dub
really helped me week together worked
out when we first start at Stanford and
we now teach it in individual places
when we go out into the world and take
these ideas and these models of
interaction and conversation are
absolutely foundational and they're
they're pure cybernetics in my sense of
the word which is this historical
discipline which is all about
understanding purpose and expressing
systems that have purpose
yeah and would you say that the idea of
interaction and feedback that goes back
and evolution very very far but when
were the first times that we became
conscious of it was it around the right
around the first proto-language time
this is not my province but I would
venture to say that language is the
beginning of consciousness that did I
mean it's a slippery slope philosophers
have been arguing it for a long time I
conformed to the definition that comes
from cybernetics which is awareness is
me apprehending things perceptual things
and consciousness is us sharing an
understanding of that apprehension
sharing so share it awareness as
consciousness in cybernetics that's not
quite what other people mean that's
that's good though I like that yeah yeah
so so I have the awareness of this
feedback and then if you also have the
awareness then it's shared if we are
aware of the other having the awareness
yeah
then we share something then we have a
social system yeah yeah and then with
language we elaborate and evolve that
social system when we create culture and
society and monsters and happiness and
grief and
all kinds of so the so the fundamental
layer is to have some sort of shared
consciousness between people yeah and so
that and that's why when you when we
look at the world around us we don't see
people on transit systems that just
start punching people that's a shared
consciousness to not do that well be
civilized
yes I mean there are some steps in
between yeah and and one of those steps
is agreements not just that this is
making a noise and that there's
something here but rather an agreement
about what we valued like paper
currencies function in society yes
that's a good example another name to
mention is Humberto Maturana who's a
Chilean biologist and I would say
sovereign edition still alive very very
influential in many communities
including the cybernetics community he's
sort of second generation to heintzman
forces first generation and Monterey now
says that we need to decide what we want
in order to move together in a coherent
society and that's about what we value
that's what what what we would call it
but the fundamental that he says in a
wonderful essays written called meta
design so meta design in Montana will
find that he says what do we want to
conserve so we have this technology and
we want to go to Mars and we want to
build electric cars and maybe we want to
save the planet and maybe we don't but
what do we want to conserve as all of
these changes are happening and is
fundamental is do we want to conserve
the value of living together that's an
open question in some societies and if
the answer is yes
then we can decide what technology we
make or don't make yeah what actions we
take or don't death in the world so
there's a kind of cadence here
shared experience somehow led the
nervous system to be able to create a
language for describing and coordinating
and layering up concepts and values and
knowledge and these things are
agreements in a kind of flux world it's
not about the physical world but it's
this space of agreements right this
social stuff that goes on and in that
social space we create norms or laws
sometimes or rules which is I'm not
going to punch you in the face when I
see you on the subway and it's a
consequence of that we can build further
and build further and build further or
not or we can destroy yeah that's also
up to us having this sort of species
agreement about some fundamental
principles seems to be really important
with the proliferation of technology
yeah I just we're just approaching too
many possible extinction scenarios yes
to not have this global conversation
about we're in just came out of an
extinction scenario with nuclear war
right
so I'm justified why are we not having a
full-fledged global conversation it's
interesting that it's taken us to the
scare of AI to worry about this in a
more serious way I hope I hope it's not
lip service yeah I mean all the big
companies are joining nonprofits that
are about ethics and AI and blah blah
blah and you have people on one side
saying you know as the Monty Python
thing goes we're done fall we're done
for and then you have the people who say
it's gonna be fine and then you get
jaron lanier who's you know kind of
brilliant third point of view where he
says no wait a minute
you know this is ridiculous what where
can we go here and he's written anything
quite eloquently about a middle space
that's in between tristin Harris has
also been talking recently good
great yeah I noticed on a little bit and
I think he's done extraordinary work he
was the seer who saw ahead and these
issues but the global conversation about
what we want to conserve even while
we're we're obsessed with this I mean
it's amazing how much how are you I'm
you know give me a minute will you I
want to check I want to check a few
things here I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
checking out I mean it's just it's a
strange world you know yeah for people
at a table two parents and two children
all on their phones anyway Kevin Kelly
wrote a book awhile ago I think was a
book called what technology wants I'm
not a violent man but that really pissed
me off because attributing to a
technology a desire no that's that's
irresponsible to suggest that we are not
responsible for the technology we may
yet and again much Ronnie's very
eloquent honest we just technology
doesn't determine us unquote we
determine what the technology is to be
and that's a question of what we wish to
conserve what our values are yeah again
just seems to be such an important
conversation to have is again what are
we doing with the smartphone technology
um how are we leveraging that how are we
leveraging the good in that how are you
being aware of the bad same thing with
all these other technologies that are
emerging
so this systems thinking applied to
interaction design I'm very interested
to hear about how these sort of feedback
systems are part of how your students
are designing and so what have been some
of the interesting designs that they've
come up with that you've been able to
that you could share with us it's hard
to just talk about them it would be fun
to show you the diagram so yeah
clickable prototypes that they've played
with
let me give you one example of a
conversation system if I may yeah a
student of mine chi minh lin has always
been interested in social justice and
the project at the end of the
cybernetics course is one in which they
can take any of the models that they've
learned first sort of feedback variety
second-order feedback bio cost which is
something we might get into in
conversation and they can look into the
world and find a system that they want
to express using any of those models and
she picked up the story of the Korean
comfort women Korean women during World
War two
you know the story who were conscripted
and I know what the right word is to
provide services sexual and otherwise
and she mapped a conversation between
the US government the Korean government
and the Japanese government about who
would say what to the other in order to
get what outcome for whom and it comes
out on a big poster now this is a set of
nested feedback systems where I the u.s.
say I will give money to this group if
this group does the following thing
Jenny yeah or I will establish arms in a
particular place defense military
defense for the sake of this government
if this government will pay this money
to this group in order to compensate for
this I'm waving my hands that's
complicated
and she used the models from the course
to express the various feedback systems
involved in that so that's that's an an
out-there example closer in would be
simpler examples of redesigning reddit
or redesigning Facebook to have
different kinds of feedback what were
some of those well actually a student
now is working on a thesis pooja pottier
she's concerned that what's up what's
that in India is a primary means of
communication including news for an
entire demographic 20s 30s and the
problem arises that coming into whatsapp
and encrypted environment is this fake
news and this person just proliferate
soon so could you have an interface
which would encourage an individual
who's seeing this story could consider
is it coming from a reputable source is
it recent or old have others attributed
veracity to it or not how do you
interrupt somebody who's looking at a
thousand of these all the time to get
certain criteria and to spend less than
five minutes which seems to be the yeah
the threshold and judge what's going on
so this is feedback to an individual to
consider criteria that she's established
based on them a fair amount of research
and if they say wait a minute you know
is that really a reputable source and
then you can expand that and see
quantitative judgments and other
criteria that come along she's
essentially got twenty five different
criteria for establishing whether or not
a story is valuable has high quality is
worth believing or not and of course
she's not trying to deal with the issue
of the pure lie she's trying to deal
with the issue where well you know some
people might consider that true and
other people might disagree with it and
so on and so forth so it very quickly
rises to the level of sophisticated
interactions and sophisticated
conversations rather than simply yeah
you know
is it getting warmer in the room or not
yeah she would be good to link up with
our friends over at the knife media
easier bias out of news and they show
you the bias of the strip out of me so
yes it'd be good to that's a lovely idea
let's pursue that yeah let's mean we
will we'll make sure to connect them no
I'm glad that students are working on
such you know applicable examples of
this and you know that's also similar to
the Tristan Harris getting a
notification when I text you that says
that old Paul is currently in busy mode
you want to break his busy mode similar
to when are you reading the article to
get a notification that says hey only
12% of people have said that this is
real news right now
etc right yeah feedback all all feedback
of all kinds and then you steer from
there you would just and steer yeah yeah
yeah so when yesterday when we were
talking about all these different
biological and mechanical social systems
I wasn't thinking about cybernetics and
cyber Natisha --nz yeah cyber in
additions yeah that's that's yeah Nick
right yeah it's a little more British
than what's the other one I always
forget the other one cyber knots no
kidding Emily yeah there's an
Americanism that I don't like as much
which I've repressed obviously cyber
nutrition's is more British I prefer
mm-hm
because I learned from the British side
limitations cybernet ish ins and I
wasn't thinking so much about
cybernetics yesterday until really
tonight or last night when I was really
going into more depth and in the subject
again because in our conversation
yesterday with Rhys Jones we were
talking so much about biological systems
such as methylation with genetics indeed
with genes
and I mean that's a really good example
of getting feedback when your gene turns
on for tooth growth or for puberty or
whatever it is again it's just that's
jus that's a biological one and then we
have the the mechanical ones of
thermostats we were discussing that one
and social ones like needing to eat a
banana again that's also biological and
I have a quote I hope I have a good
question it's tell me about this yeah go
ahead it's cybernetics all the way down
it's cybernetics all the way down and
check this okay checked out check this
house so Reese and I were talking
yesterday about how up we I got him to
give a percentage then he said it was
about one percent his actual free will
and the ninety nine percent is your just
a note on the network in cybernetics so
do you have a percentage that you think
is actual free will of you deciding to
eat the banana or the Apple or is it
actually whole system thinking with your
biology and your microbiome is that's
indicating to you whether or not you
should make the choice same thing with
the temperature and cold or warm same
thing with your social cues you parsing
fake news is that all evolution from the
past ten years of your mind developing
etc where do you think you where do you
think we fit on the free will applied to
cybernetics sort of so this is where we
drift into the philosophers corner again
free will being but one of those topics
I think the first comment as a intro is
it depends on the complexity of the
system as to whether or not you can
comprehend it or not for example the
thermostat and the heating system is
very simple biology is very complex but
I can imagine knowing it the brain is
another whole crazy thing I think we
will understand how the brain works
I don't think anyone has a clue despite
what everyone is saying and I could back
that up
maybe I believe that we're a
deterministic system I don't think
there's a soul there's other agency I
don't think there's anything affecting
me I don't think there's quantum
mechanical signals coming from a remote
Dark Star that is determining anything
it's I don't go there
Tom Gruber a friend from when I was here
in Silicon Valley I haven't been in
touch with him lately
said during a conversation with an
informal club we had it was a chief
technology officers Club we started in
in 97 when I first came here he said so
Paul you're a materialist I thought oh
my god but yes I don't believe that
there are these other agencies but it's
Heinzmann Forster again it's great
always to mention Heinz pointed out even
though there's nothing affecting what's
going on in my body other than what's in
my body it's unpredictable because of
the scale of complexity of it there's
just too much going on to be able to
predict don't get me started on
uploading consciousness by the way
because then you'll have to tie me to
the chair that's a hint
so freewill some people say is a myth
because the organism is essentially a
determine on a determined machine a
deterministic machine it just does what
it does anyway and I think as a
materialist I have to agree that that's
that's true at some levels somehow I
make up stuff that makes me think I'm
really deciding but wait a minute if
consciousness is part of the
deterministic machine and I am doing an
evaluation of possibilities I do too I
do partake I have an agency in that but
so how much steering are we doing so
yeah I'm trying to get to where you're
going thanks for bringing me back I
think we're doing a lot of steering and
yet we can't deny the point about the
other 99% that you just brought up
there's so much stuff going on out here
that in front of me now are not many
choices yeah yeah so I have water here
and maybe some water that's in this I'm
not going to drink that I'm thirsty I'm
going to drink
so the world the context determines an
enormous amount I think every day I'm
thankful every day I wake up for the
world existing because I can't keep in
my mind everything I would have to
remember if the world didn't exist so
the world is partly my memory yet I
don't have to talk about a wristwatch or
a mobile phone or an implant to say that
we were side works the world is is in a
sense helping us decide works because
we're not just the organism where the
organism in the environment and again
intelligence as a property between
systems it's not a property of a system
I am intelligent in some situations and
I'm dumbass in other situation so just
talking about intelligent machines I
think is a false premise one of the many
in the world today so I don't know that
I have a percentage 1% I you know I the
question is a little bit rhetorical in
the sense that you're trying to get a
conversation going but I don't I don't
think I can quantify it other than to
recognize that I'm constantly influenced
by what's here yeah yeah and what's not
here and yet I do feel like I do have a
lot of choice I I don't think yeah i
would enjoy my life as much as it if I
thought that the choices I make whether
what song I sing or what plane I get on
is not something are you doing myself
yeah okay how about with choice ethical
hmm you said that it he made a wonderful
face the following word ethical
conversation ethical conversation face
ethical I'm not sure where you go what
was imperative in Paris oh yes the
ethical imperative so yeah question
about the ethical imperative yep is
within choice theory do we want to
enable people to have trillions of
online choices is that is it better to
continue exponentially growing that
rather than being like maybe there is
some educational content that 8 year old
or 12 year old should be checking out at
the dinner table
beautiful question so once again Heinz
phone Forrester to the rescue and he
conceived this before we had mobile
phones to proliferate our choices or
whatever they are they're not really
phones anymore and he made a wonderful
distinction between choices and options
in fact it was a whole period when
people were misquoting him of saying you
know increased the number of options and
I'm like no that's not what he said and
he would talk about this he would say I
would say that he doesn't mean a lot we
are proliferating a trillion options but
out of that trillion options how many
are viable for me right now sure sure so
maybe there's how many 25 or something
better how many the ones I might choose
because they fit me yeah
within which I would choose to be Who I
am or choose to be who I wish to become
by making that choice which is a pretty
decent way to understand news feed
technology the news feed algorithm so
that brings it down to 25 choices from a
trillion options and then further more
than you parse the 25 to find the one
that you want to read yeah so we've
helped a little
right we've gone from a trillion to 25
yeah but how then do you make those
options possible to explore I should
have said choices the narrowed choices
possible to explore in a way that I call
humane so I'm working on an idea now
called the humane interface can I ask
you to participate in a parable I would
love to and then I'll be able to get to
the point yeah
ask me where there's good pizza all
right Paul where is there good pizza I'm
glad you asked me that Alan there's
fabulous pizza right across the street
at Luigi's pizza mm-hmm now ask me why
is it good pizza so why is Luigi's pizza
good pizza screw you I'm not gonna tell
you why why won't you tell me why well
I'll tell you in a moment why I won't
tell you but you can tell me now why
doesn't Google tell you because I just
described
it says here's the first choice I'm not
talking about sponsor yeah first choice
second tracer choice I can't say Thank
You Google really great want to know
more about Luigi's why did you say it's
good for me
or why did you say it's good in general
or why did you say this review is better
than that read you're not telling me
you're not transparent I claim that is
not ethical mmm now we know why they
don't tell us right its proprietary its
algorithmic you can game it if you if
people know but they have the black but
that doesn't satisfy me same thing can
be said about what you see in your news
feeds as well that's where I'm yeah
that's exactly what I'm here if you're
not transparent about evening unethical
I would reject you as a friend if you
wouldn't tell me why you're saying the
things you're saying I would reject from
another human being
lack of transparency yes why do I allow
a machine to be not transparent yeah
yeah if you were coming on to the show
and I wasn't telling you why I'm doing
what I'm doing I'd be like I'm not
coming under your shade yeah exactly
yeah and if you were a like a partner of
mine like a romantic partner and then
you were whole withholding information
from me I'd be like you're not being
transparent we don't need a date anymore
etc this word Trust is coming up here
yeah so how can you trust an interaction
mmm where you don't feel like it's
reliably transparent yeah in what it's
telling you and why it's telling you
that and very similar to where our
taxpayer dollars go in the government
system it's endless yeah it's it's
really endless so we're on this path
about choice and I have in front of me
now you have given me Google has given
me 25 choices it's inhumane if sorry
it's unethical if I can't say why was
Luigi's pizza good pizzas and again
there are classes of goodness for making
it a choice for me it could be other
people's reviews it could be its opinion
your opinion that's fine but I want to
know your opinion is
the opinion of a thousand reviewers is
the opinion of a service bless you thank
you the opinion of a service that's
making a thousand dollars on showing you
this I mean it's perfectly fine if you
say you make money by proposing
something then I can jump there yet
right
transparency about all all of these
different aspects so all of this I think
is quite important especially as we move
into interfacing with more and more
machines yes yeah humans don't get away
with being non transparent why yeah I
mean why should machines yeah and then
there's a problem of a machine learning
or even the machine doesn't know mmm
right the neural net thing it doesn't
have criteria that it can share with you
it's looking for patterns and those
patterns are meaningless in terms of
categories or values or preferences so
machine learning is another whole bag of
worms when it comes to transparency and
that's a known issue I'm glad of that
I'm not sure that parables like Luigi's
parable will use Pizza parable I like
that one that's a good one I I think
it's effective in making the voice if
I'm in front of a group of students or
in an audience and when I say I just
described Google there's a gasp it's
like whoa yes you're talking about
Google we accept this from Google and
Facebook yeah and another recommendation
oh you're yeah you don't know how the
algorithm is working for your news feed
you don't know how the governments
exactly spending your taxpayer dollars
in that lack of transparency should be
pressed we should be pressing that lack
of transparency more yes to be able to
have a more open and honest conversation
about the algorithms that are
controlling our behavior and choices I'd
like to go just a little further
yeah you're right let me go deep I love
the deep yeah the deep conversation
formula that's you've graded here Alan
it's wonderful and rare in the modern
age so my first axiom if you will is the
idea that an ethical interface is
transparent reliably transparent in both
what it says and in the reasons why it's
saying it there's a there's a second
axiom which is let's imagine that Google
now decide
that they want to tell us the reasons
behind their top three choices what
mechanism could that follow it could
follow for example the same mechanism
that we know and love in privacy
statements and terms and conditions 25
pages of stuff that no one's ever going
to bother to read it could be well that
would be ethical they would be
transparent if they were telling the
truth and reliable and so on but that
wouldn't be very helpful it would not be
in my terms it would not be humane yeah
yeah what would be humane would be my
ability to ask a question of it to say
oh you think Luigi's pizza is better how
do they do on sustainability on paying
minimum wage on gluten-free on that yeah
on values that I want to bring to the
conversation is extraordinarily
efficient compared to the alternatives
and so I'm promulgating the idea of a
conversational interface as being the
humane interface because I as
participant on the other side of this
thing going on can direct it it's we Co
participate I don't have to listen to
you for half an hour to wait for the
answer I want yeah I don't have to read
20 pages I can say what about this and
yeah so it's a with machine interfaces
the coal the coal participation the
conversation that creates a hybrid of
choice then rather than a the Machine
showing you the choice and then yeah
yeah and then you not being able to
understand why it's even up there right
I mean conversation has evolved over how
many years how long has language been
around I've heard 10,000 I don't know
don't know more hundred thousand yeah
yeah actually they upped the ante yeah
that's a figure so it works conversation
works that was the slogan by the way of
my company generals that's good yeah
conversation works yeah so why don't we
have conversational interfaces this
comes up now of course when we're
dealing a lot with voice
mmm-hmm and that's another yeah whole
thing you have voices now being unlocked
into all of our homes and yeah Ron what
do you think about transparency and what
are your thoughts about transparency
with the algorithms that run our world
transparency with the government systems
yeah what do you think about the
transparency of the systems and our
relationship with them I don't think
it's transparent you asked me what I
think about the transparency I think
where it's there is very little
transparency a lot of people have a hard
time with the truth accepting their own
truth as well as being truthful to
others we you know it just I don't live
in denial that I'm being lied to do you
do you think that this way of systems
thinking is helpful for understanding
reality systems thinking thinking about
yourself as something that needs to be
steered so as you have a interaction
with a will will be steered it's a this
planet is littered with lost
civilizations that have been steered
into destruction and here we are in 2018
with Mars and we'll do we deserve to go
there I don't know I'd love to be
optimistic but I I'm not that's a really
good point Ron the civilizations that
got steered into destructive directions
yeah yeah and here we are talking about
the future technologies that have the
potential to steer us in the wrong
directions let's let's segue into that
so you mentioned that
machine intelligence is not always
intelligent
and then evolve we've also been talking
about this hybrid choice walk us down
what some of your thoughts are about
these intelligent systems that are able
to impact our lives that do a lot of the
logical offloading from ourselves
yeah well symbiosis is a word that's
been around for many years to describe
the relationship between humans and
technologies Engelbart talked about a
Doong Engelbart course very important in
the history of interaction design and
Lickliter JCR Licklider who I also knew
in college for a little while
extraordinary guy he wrote about
man-machine meaning human-machine
symbiosis gender issue there which we
fixed since gender emphasis and those
ideas are to leave to the machine what's
the machine is good at and to leave to
people what people are good at and to
bring them together in this
complementary way and AI of course is
stupendous at certain kinds of pattern
matching machine learning in particular
the successful AI let's call it that
people should talk about machine
learning oh yes that's that AI thing
that's worked because for 50 60 years
there have been other proposals that
really haven't worked very well and
machine learning is powerful as I say
over and over again for pattern matching
but it doesn't think the way we think
and it doesn't do what we do so some
domains remain untouched while some are
over touched so the media gets a hold of
stories including the tech media I won't
name names who say well you know
computers are better at diagnosing
x-rays than people now maybe maybe not
let's not go too fast with that
mm-hmm what I'm trying to get to though
is
the values that we have as human beings
are those that are the most important
and again as I said earlier with Mon
Tirana we bring the values to the way
the technology is used and if the value
is profit and two billion users to
whatever benefit then we're down a we're
far down a slippery slope and can we
back out and all of that kind of thing
so those are the issues there I love
that we got it we got to bring the
values yeah as the forefront principle
to the development of the technologies
yeah yeah I mean we have a choice as a
society interested in growing quarterly
profits and growth and big is better
than ethics or yeah maybe yeah then
that's the problem of the world that's
not the problem of the technology it's a
question of where we want to where we
want to where we want to go what we want
what we need and that's a huge
conversational point that we talk about
on here is the ethical considerations of
the economic and financial systems yeah
yeah yeah so but put me back on track
Alan I think you're asking a question
about where society is gonna go or yeah
yeah and and how do we balance out the
need for a little bit of ethical
consideration in the economic and
financial markets while simultaneously
needing to continue promulgating
innovation and and invent yeah invention
so I think providing value to people
yeah so questioning the values behind
machine intelligence the values behind
machine learning specifically and the
values behind human society that's very
broad he stated
there's an implied worshipping of zeros
and ones when you have the algorithm as
[Music]
the the ultimate icon the ultimate
tallies Mountain the ultimate thing that
you're worshipping so we believe in
algorithms and we trust them and we say
that they're great and that's our future
in this internet you know world that we
have I want to remind us all something
that I think we can lay at the feet of
Google of the feet of Larry and Sergey
because when they started using the word
algorithm they erased the word heuristic
and there's an important difference an
algorithm is something that is so well
crafted that it always gets you the
answer if you give it the right inputs
it will give you the output so
arithmetic addition division these are
algorithms you give them to numbers and
you get out the answer every time a
heuristic is the situation where not so
much where maybe 80% of the time you get
a good answer but it's not perfect
algorithms are perfect heuristics are
imperfect so losing that word heuristic
to describe what the technology is doing
is already deceiving us into thinking
we're getting more than we're really
good so the loss of that vocabulary is I
think unfortunately now I'm not saying
that you can't make a machine
intelligent in the sense that I meant
earlier in relationship particular
mystics are a major aspect of systems
thinking yeah totally yeah and if and if
they if we can be more transparent about
how it is just a heuristic yes yeah that
would help even that's the lack of
transparency thank you for putting it
that way yeah that's a lack of
transparency so I also believe that you
can have conversations with machines not
like the ones we have today with Alexa
that ain't no conversation conversation
again is one in which things evolve you
learn more the other side learns more
you create a common context you have
shared values ultimately but certainly
share it information so if I say the
next day play the song that you played
yesterday please alexxa notice I can say
it at the end as well as at the
beginning yeah so it's not a
relationship if I have to start from
scratch every time yeah and that's the
major issue with the conversational
interfaces we have today it doesn't
create a shared relationship yeah that
can be done that's a database thing
please focus on that somebody because
until you do I'm gonna be really pissed
every morning when I get up and I have
to repeat the same thing to alexa
receiver your katana or mm-hmm
what's the other one from Sam's Google
home Mini Google home but yeah there's a
big speed I think it's Samsung Oh
everybody's gone so what am I trying to
say conversations with machines I think
when they begin to become more like
human conversations will be
extraordinary and there are design
patterns for those I've been sitting
among them for 40 years Gordon Pasque
who was at the architecture machine at
MIT which is the predecessor to the
Media Lab Nicholas Negroponte they hired
him was talking conversation four years
ago I'm like that I don't care what you
got over there that and I've been
following that path for a long time and
maybe path is worth a brief excursion
but to try to stay on point
conversational machines machines that
have intelligence in certain situations
human-machine symbiosis these are all
fabulous things but what are the values
behind them and unfortunately the values
behind whatever we're doing in any of
those areas now are techno values or
business values they are not humane and
ethical values and until they are we're
going to become the product we all say
about Facebook right rather than the
user of the product to our advantage
yeah what are you will be programming
ethics into AI robots
every damn coder on the planet it's
gonna be programming those things
implicitly or explicitly we had this
little flurry recently when people said
oh the algorithm made me do it or the
algorithm right the algorithm made the
mistake oh you know the company says oh
that was just our algorithm we didn't
make the mistake our oh my goodness yeah
so we're beyond that now a little bit
right I think yeah they got called out
for that gosh and you know either that's
incredibly stupid or incredibly naive
and I don't wanna either of those ruling
the world of these giant domains that
are so much Ron Ron and I have this
ongoing joke that people rarely take
blame for their their own actions we try
and take blame for our own actions as
often as possible so well that's ethical
yeah okay what what what about what
about artificial intelligence posing an
existential threat where do you sit on
that well others make a living at this I
worry about it a lot whether it's a
drone somewhere that's programmed to do
something nasty yeah
whether it's pure surveillance
everywhere I'm nesting
every I mean Alexa knows more about me
than I care to admit but more serious of
the are the implicit programming so the
prejudice that's involved in judges that
use programs to decide whether or not to
incarcerate somebody I mean this is just
unconscionable it's not a strong enough
word for this kind of thing but it's
everywhere and the distinction between
that and some valuable use is almost
indistinguishable because we are not
starting from the values and then moving
to the technology saying oh I can make
that let's use that Oh a walk over here
fine that's us to do so we're not value
driven we're technology advancement
driven does it have to be dystopian no
is it kind of dystopian now
yeah again that's why I should probably
read him more carefully before I say
this again but jaron lanier seems to be
a guy who's saying these guys say this
and these guys say that so you know the
people who are scared to death about AI
and the people who are the opposite
extreme which is oh no we're fine don't
worry about it I mean this this drives
me crazy both of these things drive me
crazy they don't make any sense to me I
don't really have an articulate response
other than the say can we talk yeah and
can we talk about the ethics of it and
yeah
what's being driven and are we starting
from thinking the technology is doing
something to us or the business should
be the rule or are we starting from
what's humane and what is ethical and
that's where I'm trying to work in it in
this very modest way in interaction
design and saying what is an ethical
interface what is a humane interface
yeah and can we operationalize that so
I'm not some ivory tower guy saying it
would be nice if I'm saying if we follow
these patterns then we might be closer
to ethics and humane Ness yeah and that
that is so good to have interaction
design kind of be that medium of
feedback and then steering and then over
and over again I really I really like
that about where you come from in how
we're gonna implement this conversation
into the world about these technologies
and implementing ethics and values into
them okay how about what do you what do
you think about the global ruling elite
do you think one exists power is clearly
concentrated
if that's what you mean by the global
ruling elite then the answer is yes and
should one endeavor to join the elite to
make I'm half I don't know I there's no
easy answer to them you know I grew up
at the I was a little young but in the
60s so-called when you know we were all
waiting for the revolution to come
I play Che Guevara by the way in a show
that couldn't go on one night because
the theater was full of tear gas in
Cambridge Massachusetts because of the
demonstrators at the time so we couldn't
go on to talk about a revolutionary
because this non revolution that was
taking place outside that we thought was
going to make a difference didn't really
common sixties changed a lot of things
but apparently it didn't change the
power base I don't know how to change
the power base you know the the new
awareness of a lot of things black lives
matter the whole recent thing in
Hollywood I think are incredibly
important awareness-raising things and
maybe there's a change there but all of
this is about changing the power and I
don't know I don't know how to do that
what do you think about the
socio-economic wealth
stratification that we currently have
eight eight people have as much wealth
as the bottom four billion there's a lot
of instability that could come from that
what do you think about that and how we
could potentially solve that I again
this is way above my pay grade
I think it's appalling and
unconscionable and is it irreversible I
don't know I try and work in the domain
that I feel like I have some some
insights and some hope that by
influencing designers to think in ways
that are more humane and more ethical is
really the best I think that I can do
and I also think a shift from a techno
centric AI centric world to a cybernetic
centric world which again is not
Bionic implants and not yet
biomechatronics and not freezing that
people by the way I want to make sure
you know that that's not freezing dippy
is an important shift because it returns
us to purpose and it ultimately returns
us to yea expressing the values by which
we want to live and deciding if we want
to live together and if we do then we
would know how to act better what do you
think about how we can maximize human
potential it's an easy answer for me
it's all about conversation so
conversation is the foundation of
relationship and shared history and
Trust once we trust each other we're
faster at interacting mm-hm and we can
explore possibilities with each other we
can make choices among the options and
we can then coordinate our action so we
can agree that you'll design something
and I'll build it or that we will design
it together maybe build it together
collaboration cooperation these are all
words that emerge as a consequence of
being able to have conversations and
ethical conversations in which we're Co
participants are important that's not to
say that I feel like I have value in
every single decision I have a certain
range capabilities am i recognizing that
and you recognising that means that we
can share the responsibility and I'll
have everyone in every decision so there
are principles and cybernetics that are
actually quite actionable about that
having to do with variety in the
conversation and designing a
conversation for its variety so to
increase human potential we could get
better at having conversations in which
we move forward in a coherent and
co-participant Ori that's a redundant
way of putting it yeah set of
interactions that is beautifully said I
will ways like to talk about equanimity
we like to talk about having a growth
mindset we like to talk about
understanding people's journey and how
they got to where they're at yes all of
those asked
are crucial to having a conversation
with someone especially someone that may
disagree with you and that is actually
very healthy for conversation if you
enable it to be if you practice having
that tough conversation over and over
again so we've lost a lot of that has as
often said I mean people talk about
Washington is not really being
cooperative even yeah and sherry Turkle
writes very eloquently on the loss of
conversation book reclaiming
conversation the title says it all and
our capacity to have conversation is
diminished by all of the things going on
in the world a lot of which are
technological but those are consequences
of our value systems of the value
systems that create systems that make us
go down certain paths make us is that
too strong that encourages us you
encouraged us that entice us yeah that
make us addicted to and the Tristana so
yeah all right what do you think about
us being alone in the cosmos I think
it's impossible that we're alone it just
seems I mean how did we get here what
cybernetics would say is that we got
here through evolutionary patterns
processes that move toward higher and
higher orders of complexity to the point
of the complexity of consciousness and
language and society and everything that
we're building on the planet including
the stuff that's going to snuff us out
those conditions are rare but the
universe is I think when I last looked
pretty big and more than large enough to
have other stuff going on but the
distances involved are kind of crazy
yeah yeah so I'm not sure we'll ever
know yeah and those who dream about that
I think should be encouraged to dream my
focus would more be on the oceans than
on the cosmos because that's near at
hand yeah and my that's my feeling about
Mars if you're about to ask me about
them no be nice to go to Mars yeah great
but you know I think we should focus on
what we're [ __ ] up here before we do
something that yeah exactly
recently was that an event where I heard
that he loans decisions about Mars were
actually held held back with his
interest of helping make sure earth is
in good condition first and then good
yeah so completely agreed also oceans
are super unexplored 95% of explorador
habitation that we could build on top
there's amazing ways that we could live
on on the oceans so ok agreed about the
vastness of the cosmos and I always
think about the the ways that life could
have evolved around other stars so how
about what do you thinks the most
beautiful thing in the world that's such
a difficult question difficult in the
best sense I have I have my own bias of
course we all have our own advice and I
think just looking in someone else's
eyes is the most beautiful thing because
it can happen anywhere it can mean most
anything and it's the foundational
connection that we have as species it's
a language of its own that would be my
answer I didn't have that answer into
you just as I love that answer that's
why we like keeping it and Radek I
haven't prepared that that's such a good
one because you're right it can be
something as short as just a glance and
it can speak so much Wow and it's a
gateway to the soul or those yet spirit
yeah there's young much and and it's so
available and so underused yeah you know
something to be absolutely cultivated
absolutely I love speaking with the eyes
yes let's talk about that you don't even
need to make any vocal noises at
somebody I can just yes you can
communicate a whole language that way
yes and all right how about are we in a
computer simulation
if I weren't worried about your rug I
would have spit out the water just now
you know I think that's a really stupid
question I don't think I don't think
you're stupid for asking it but I think
it's a stupid question anything expand
that right why it's so unnecessary well
first of all it's unnecessary
you know Occam's razor which says the
simplest explanation is always the one
that always the one is the most likely
one to be true no I don't think we're in
a simulation I don't think it would be
possible to simulate this you think it's
possible to gnome you like this why I
will claim again as I mentioned in
passing that it's possible to make a
mechanism that's intelligent the way the
brain is because the brain is a
mechanism again I don't think anyone has
a clue to that I think this guy Gordon
Pasque has a pattern for it
and has a lot of proposals that haven't
been followed at all but I just think
it's unbearably complex and it's easier
to do it than to simulate it so why why
would we add a layer of complexity on
top of something that we can just be
okay is that satisfying yeah yeah of
course of course my answer yes yes of
course all right and we have this fun
game that we got snow in presses a 100
questions categories are loving
relationships and like sex personality
and emotion did I sign up for this what
you don't you didn't down you didn't put
the cat in the categories are wrong oh
well we'll be able to find okay working
money travel life and death self family
and friendships culture and taste what
are you thinking you going to pick one
pick a category oh I want to pick self
of course you don't pick self sure all
right what's the sign what's the graphic
for that all right cool it's a little
human thinking let's find this I assume
as this is the epistemological self and
not the mean self I think so I think so
let's see we are
I almost there here we are okay alright
let's let's let's give you a couple
options here doo doo doo doo doo all
right we don't have a heart stop doing I
do want to put in a plug for something I
think we will
we won't okay yeah yeah all right all
right Paul what's your question is there
an art to loading the dishwasher is
there an art to loading the dishwasher
what a softball question I mean you know
ask me a hard question sometime of
course there's an art to loading this
one all right let's hear about the art
there's an art in every action and every
process it's a question of whether we
choose to accept the mission
I love loading dishwasher as if it were
an art and I don't mean some kind of
anal retentive you know pattern that I
follow every single time but it's an act
of gracefulness yeah and an act of
mindfulness and a necessary boring
horrible act that I can turn into a work
of art yeah yeah exactly
and I try to every day if we dance
through the universe than this becomes
fun that's right that was interesting
question is who's playing the music yeah
who [ __ ] the music yeah hopefully each
individual person's vibing at their own
frequency that's right you're not
forcing me to take a particular yeah
yeah take-take-take know I had the
feeling that you were trying to feed me
oh I took it too yeah give me the one
that you haven't seen the tops are there
yup yeah
do people envy you I doubt it and I envy
her I doubt it and I have no idea okay
what is the plug so the plug I wanted to
mention is I'm doing a project at the
College for Creative Studies yes called
the colloquy 2018 project okay and I
doubt that you'll be able to see this
but Gordon passed 50 years ago did an
exhibit at the Institute for
Contemporary Arts in London which
consisted of these Mobile's some were of
male figures and some are female yeah
well so they rotate on their own axis
and they make sounds and shine lights
and under certain circumstances they
stop and they coordinate with each other
and they have a relationship that's
brief
then after a while they're satisfied and
they keep going 50 years ago he was
exploring the idea of machines talking
to machines and of course a human being
could come into the gallery with a
flashlight or block the light that's
there or make sounds and try to interact
with the thing but it was fundamentally
machines talking to machines so we've
raised about 80% of the money to build
this between now and May at the College
for Creative Studies in which we're
going to reproduce what it was and how
it worked full size full scale it's
about 12 feet by 12 feet okay but
because we're not going to reproduce the
technology he used 50 years ago we're
using Arduino and you know very complex
sensors and all kinds of things we can
reprogram it we can program it with
voice with AI with cloud computing with
all of these other things so the
students who have been doing the
archeology of understanding how it kind
of worked there's a movie there's some
flowcharts there's some descriptions
they've plumbed the history and tried to
reproduce how it worked then and they're
still in the process of building it but
also they can reprogram it in 2018
so if male female robots were
interacting with each other in a certain
way in 1968 how might they interact with
each other today and so we're expecting
to open in May we've been invited to
bring it to other places the Zed cam
Arts and Media Institute in calls for a
Germany has asked that we bring it there
I'm visiting the Exploratorium later
trip good some substantial portion of
the entire exhibition the entire
exhibition was called cybernetic
serendipity and this piece my Gordon
tasks piece was called colloquy as in
colloquium or conversation of boys right
so he was talking about conversational
machines 50 60 years ago before we even
imagined yeah so I just want people to
know and they can write to me and ask
about this the project itself is it
going through a fundraiser right now yes
cool and then what's the will throw the
link in the bio they'll be great for
them as well yes people
wonderful nice this is this is good I'm
glad that you're working on a big
project like this with Dean and
worldwide there are these events about
the 50th anniversary of the whole show
from the Institute of Contemporary Arts
in London and so there's National
Academy of Sciences having something
there's a one of these things I've given
you as a paper submitted to a Liverpool
University of liberal yeah conference
yeah yeah on the on the history of AI
and social behavior I think something
anyway thank you for letting yeah yeah
this is great
I'm really happy that you guys are
working on this and yeah we'll go ahead
and put the link in the bio definitely
give them up so we want to thank
everyone for tuning in we really
appreciate it
you can follow Paul pandeiro on Twitter
first name last name on Twitter you can
visit his website just pandeiro dot-com
all this awesome content is on there we
have a lot of other great content that's
up and coming if you guys find this
content useful like comment subscribe
share it with other people become a
patron get access to exclusive events
exclusive content and guest Q&A so much
more check us out there thank you to
Ronnie Vargas our producer and director
they do an amazing job thank you is it
really it's only five minutes have gone
by since we started yeah yeah only five
minutes of gum I think about good
conversation exactly exactly and merch
merch coming soon get your get your are
we in a computer simulation that's
coming up and thanks for tuning in and
we'll be back see ya
[Music]